hello we're from st. Rose and I'm a
grandmother you know and Shannon you
Rena
and we have a question for you dr. John
that day as an astrophysicist do you
think of applying existence in the dark
regions of our solar system in a couple
of Oh hi Gregory and Shannon you're
asking about are there more planets out
there in the outer solar system I think
so of course people are looking we've
known about the classical planets for a
long time we've demoted to Pluto from
Planet status to being a dwarf planet
but we've already discovered other dwarf
planets farther out in the solar system
that are even bigger than Pluto
so calculation says there are thousands
of them out there and possibly we'll
find them we're certainly turning them
up occasionally and bigger telescopes
that can observe the most distant stars
in the universe can also discover the
most distant planets in the solar system
we think they're going to be all dwarf
planets but I think maybe you're asking
is there another big planet like Jupiter
or Saturn out there and chances are no
but we do have to go look and see
so there is a mission about to be
launched called the wise mission and the
wise mission is a wide field Infrared
Survey Explorer satellite if there's a
planet out there that's bright like
Jupiter but we just never happen to have
turned it up this mission would probably
discover it